Hi Frankie.
Hello.
Get in here.
Nothing like that first drink of the day
Go on, drink up! Enjoy
They tell me, you're quite a dancer?
No? Well
how about a dance anyway?
Hey give them back. What's the big idea?
Frankie...
Frankie, when did you get back? How are you?
You all right? You know.....
- The monkey is gone.
- Let me look at you.
- Not even a postie card.
- You can't read anyway.
- You're good at drawing pictures.
-Oh, you goof-ball.
How's the lost dog business?
As soon as they see me walking around, people start
locking up their mutts.
l tell you folks just don't have that trust in their fellow
man anymore.
- Hey Antic, look who's out.
- Frankie!
- You all right? Good kid.
- Enough already, buy me a drink.
- Look what the cat dragged in.
- Frankie!
You've been gone so long, l thought maybe you'd
been made warden.
- Well you're looking good.
- Put on 6 pounds.
6 pounds!
He's been gone so long, l thought maybe he'd been
made warden.
- How was it down there Frankie?
- Greatest place you've ever seen.
l'm telling ya, ball games, great food. l even learned
how to play the drums.
You make it sound as if l missed something by not
going to jail years ago. lt's a prison, no?
More of a hospital kind. Let me show you something.
Ah, Federal Pens is always best. Ask anybody.
He's been gone so long, l think he's been made
warden.
Ever see anything so pretty.
- Don't touch!
- Hey, how'd you sneak them out Frankie?
- Them guys gave them to me in the band.
-They let you have a band?
Yeah, l was in it. They chipped in and bought me
these when l left.
Long time. How was it there? Bad?
- lt wasn't bad.
- Six months. You could hardly wait, l bet?
- Come over to my place
- No thanks.
You broke? Now ain't you being stupid? lt's for free.
l don't need it, that's all. l kicked it.
Oh, kicked it?
- One of them.
- l mean it.
Sure
l'll be around.
Frankie, don't do it. Don't start up with that peddlar
again.
l'd rather chop my arm off, before l'd let him touch it.
this Dr. Lennick who took care of me down at the
hospital, real good guy he told me at least 10
times........
He told me Frankie, you get out of here and take one
fix, you're hooked again.
Don't worry about me buddy boy
Let's get out of here. Thanks Antic.
Take care of the dog for me. l've got a customer
coming to get it.
- Don't let him give you no gas.
- Him? l ain't going to be around here long enough to
let him bother me.
- Don't let him give you no gas.
- Him? l ain't going to be around here long enough to
let him bother me.
- l'm going to get me a job in a big-name band.
- You're kidding?
What do you think l stretching my wrist for buddy-o?
The guy that teaches drumming down there, says l'm
a natural.
l can't miss he says. Arm's made of pure gold.
You mean a job winding these drums?
- l've got everything planned too. Going to call myself
Jack Duvall.
- Probably l ain't going to see you around so much
then, huh?
Maybe l can set something up for you. Carrying the
instruments or something.
- Travelling around the country high-type night clubs.
- How does that sound to you? When is it going to
be, when??
Right away, today. l'm the kind of guy boy that when
l move, watch my smoke. But l'm going to need
some good clothes.
- Well you go on up. l'm going to find you some.
- Yeah, yeah, size 39.
- 39.
- Stripes.
Something nice.
You stop that noise! You and your husband or l throw
you both out.
Who is landlord? Me! You do as l say.
Your mother's eye socks, l do like you say!
Frankie...
You look great! How're ya feeling Frankie? l mean....
- Fine, fine, just fine. Hi ya landlord.
- She and husband fight all the time. Hollerthrow
things!
- Nothing changes.
- This is respectable house, and l am respectable
man!
Respectable my eye! Go on get out, you're late for
the parole board.
Frankie...
You're home.
Oh Frankie, l love you so much!
l've missed you so.
l've been so lonely Frankie, without you.
- l've been so lonely without you.
- Sssh, stop crying.
Let me look at you.
- My eyes are going to be all red.
- No, you look fine.
- ls the cold sore gone?
- Yeah, you look real good.
l've had this cold sore, and l wanted to look real nice
for you when you came back. l was afraid that it
wouldn't be gone, so l put this cream on.
Everything is going to be all right..
Oh, you didn't see. Look, V got the cake by the
bakery, but the sign l made. Sort of like a welcome
home.
Gee, it's like a real party or something.
Real nice.
- How are you Frankie?
- l'm clean.
Sure?
- l kicked it for keeps.
- Did it hurt?
How was it there for you?
They treated me fine down there. There was this
doctor, Dr. Lennex, he was real good to me.
Frankie! Did you miss me?
Of course l missed you. What kind of silly question is
that?
Of course l missed you. Honest, no kidding.
- What have you got there?
- You'll see. Oh, l brought you something.
- Oh, it an exquisite thing.
- You like it? l made it myself, out of cigarette
wrappers.
lt's just an exquisite thing, that's all.
-You made it? Yeah.
Yeah, for a hobby like. You see part of the cure, was
to keep yourself busy, doing things you enjoy
Like for instance, l wanted to learn to drum and
music. And Dr. Lennex got them to help me do it.
During the day I was kept busy enough, butduring the
night I'd get restless and I wanted to keep my mInd of
the craving.
l made that.
- There's something important l've got to tell you.
- What?
l forget right now.
A whistle?
l was scared sometimes being alone. So Vi got it for
me and l should blow for her when l wanted her
Go on, you were telling me.
The first thing you do when you get there, is you talk
to a doctor for about 2 hours..
l know! l know what it is. l know what l wanted to tell
you.
Vi took me to this movie and the girl's kid brother had
a friend and who do you think he looked like?
- Who?
- You!
That was a good movie. Stage show was real good
too. We owe Vi 80 cents for the movie, l was broke.
We owe her for the cake too.
How come you didn't have any money? Swrick didn't
kick in regualr?
- No.
- Well, he was suppose to.
lt was his joint they raided, not mine. l was just the
dealer.
l kept my mouth shut and took the rap.
- lf he didn't send 50 a month regular, how much did
he?
- Well he sent 50, but not regular
See Vi had to kick in for me sometimes.
She took good care of you? You had fun with her?
Yeah.....but not like when you're here.
lt was terrible being alone Frankie...and my legs when
they hurt, she don't massage like you.
- What do they say by the clinic?
- l stopped going by that goofy clinic.
The clinic must know what right. You got to start the
clinic again. You got to get well.
Vi dreamed that this new doctor around the corner, he
cured me. l'd have gone to him already, but he ain't
free like the clinic.
But now you're back making money again, and l'll go.
l'm finished with Shrika. l won't deal for him no more.
But you always deal. You're a dealer. You're the best
dealer in the business.
No more. l'm a drummer now..
- Don't make jokes Frankie. l never know when
you're making jokes.
- Who's joking? Listen.
Nice huh?
lt's Dr. Lennex. l told him my whole life story from
when l was born, almost.
And about you and me. But he told me that if l lived
when l got out, like l lived before l went in there,
chances are l would be hooked again in no time...
So that's why l want to get with a band.
Listen.
- How's that?
- Cute.
- What did you tell him about me, this doctor?
- l told him about getting some money and getting
you well.
Then he said getting with a band was a good way to
go at it.
He even gave me the name of a guy right here in
town, to get a job.
l mean with this man, if he's ever heard of this great
doctor. Most time these things just don't come
through.
- l got this.
- What is it?
lt's a letter from the Doc.
- l think l'll go call him now
- Now? Let's talk about it tomorrow.
- You'll be all right.
- You've haven't even tasted the cake yet.
- l'll only be a minute.
- l'll be right up. No, now Frankie.
First, taste a piece of nice....cake.
- Hey, you coming baby?
- Yeah, l'm coming John.
- Molly!
l want to talk to Mr. Harry Lane, please.
- How about it huh?
- Machine, Mr. Franke Machine.
Yeah, l've got a letter of introduction for him. From Dr
Lennex.
- Hello Frankie.
- Dr. Martin Lennex.
- How have you been Molly?
- Okay.
Come on baby, let's go.
A guy l met while you was away.
- Mr. Lane. l've got a letter for you.
- Come on, what do you say kiddo?
This afternoon huh? Well l sure do appreciate it Mr.
Lane, thank you very much.
Okay, good-bye.
Frankie! A new thing, by Brax Department Store. No
sales girls, you just help yourself.
lt's what they call an honor system.
What's the matter Frankie? Feel that material. And l
figured, as long as l'm there....
Nice huh?
You all right? Frankie?
- l got the drummerjob.
-Already? Wow!
When l move, l move like a streak.
Think it looks all right?
How come you ask me all of a sudden?
- l just want to know if it looks all right Sash?
-And my name ain't Sash, it's Sophia.
What's the matter?
Nothing's the matter, 'cept how would you feel if your
spine was hurting?
- Why didn't you say so?
- On account of it being your first day back, and l
didn't want you to worry.
- Don't be like that Sash.
- ls it bad? Maybe the new doctor will do me some
good huh?
- We'll go see him when l get back.
- Oh, take me now Frankie.
Sash, l've got this appointment. You know how much
it means to me..
We'll go as soon as l get back.
- Please Frankie.
- l'll hurry.
- Well give me a little more massage first then, huh?
- Sash, l'm doing this for you to get some money so
we can get you a good doctor.
- Frankie...
- Look, l'll get you a dog too. Get her a dog, will ya?
l'll give the job my personal attention. Just have
confidence in the management.
Wish me luck Sash.
Frankie!
Wait. Wait Frankie!
- Wishes or wants, what could l do?
- Yeah, she just don't realize.
- Shut up punk. Just don't realize. How would you
like to be nailed to a chair?
Frankie, Frankie, how are you? Well, it didn't do you
no harm, did it Frankie?
- You look good.
- That's right Shrika, it was a real country club.
- They give you this when they let you out?
- They didn't give him nothing. l got it at Brax's.
l come as soon as l hear you are out. l figured you
was worried about getting this job again.
Don't worry. Shrika don't forget.
- Job's waiting.
- You need a dealer, you say?
Do you? No! l've been dealing myself and l've built
up a game like nobody's business. l've got a great
following. The play is bigger than ever.
- l hear that you wasn't doing so good.
- From who?
When l say ''great'', l don't mean a lot, a few..loaded.
- So, what do you want me for?
- Like l'm telling you. l take care of my friends.
Can l polish your halo Shrika, only a quareter
Look, l've been doing all right. But l don't say the
customers like me better than they like you. The
dealer makes the house.
- What do you say?
- No!
- You're dealing for some otherjoint?
- l ain't dealing for nobody l ain't dealing for nobody
no more!
ls that the way you re-pay me? Didn't l send money
to Sash? Here, l've gone and told all my friends that
you'd be working for me again.
What am l suppose to do? As far as l'm concerned,
you can go back to matching pennies with school
kids.
Who is he?
- ls that a thing with them?
- They see each other. You want to meet him?
- See ya Frankie.
Hey you...
- Get in dealer.
- Who me? What for?
- You too punk.
- l didn't do nothing.
Now wait, listen. l'm on my way to get a job. lt's
important to me.
- You can pick me up some other time.
- l just need an hour
Are you looking at being sued for liable or something.
l could sue you right now
- You're looking good Dealer, real good.
- When did they let you out? Monday
- What's the charge?
- Shop lifting from Brax, this suit.
- Who told you a thing like that?
- A little birdie.
-A little bird with a cigar.
- Shrika.
ls that all you could stay out of trouble, two days,
dealer?
Listen, l got a chance at a job, playing with a band.
Honest, if you don't believe me, call the guy on the
phone, he'll tell you..
- Just give me half hour, please.
-Sure, you can have my badge too.
- Book them and hold these two.
- Look, all l need is a half hour Give me a break, will
ya?
l don't make the rules dealer.
You can't hold me. l'm incapable. l ain't smart
enough to be running around loose, but l'm too goofy
to be locked up.
- Let go of the neck.
- Let go of the neck. l've got a complaint.
Let go of the neck.
Hey you, l'm talking to you.
Oh the old silent treatment huh. Let's have your
number fella..
Frankie, you got a cigarette?
Do a cigarette trick, you knowjust to break the dirty
monotomy.
Hello dealer. l come running as soon as l heard. You
want l should get you out dealer?
The store will drop the charges, but 37 bucks is a lot
of dough. How do l know you'd pay me back?
- You fink!
- lt'd be different if you was dealing for me.
- lf you want to deal for me, l can get you out.
- You dirty lousy, stool pigeon.
l don't know what you mean.
Just trying to do you a favor.
Yes, or no?
Okay...
He took off like a whipped dog. He's scared of you
Frankie.
- Nobody's ever been scared of me.
-Them Krautz was scared of you. You was a big man
in the army.
Big man. l was the guy that picked the fly spots out of
the pepper.
Get me out!
Can you get me a fix?
- Big Ace's and here we go down and dirty
- Better luck next time.
l'll see that. Coffee!
Doesn't mean a thing, unless you have the King. Bet
more, win more.
ou still take tips dealer? Or don't they pay in the
music game?
What happened to that big job you had lined up?You
stink out the joint? Give us a fresh deck..
l decide when we need a fresh deck at this table..
- Hey Louie. Borrow me a dirty dollar.
- Get back at the door, lame-brain.
- l take orders only from Frankie.
-Don't give me lip you cheap little hustler
Hustler? l'm ligit compared to some. Ain't no 14 year
old junkies waiting around to see me.
Do you want to die?
nd here we go, down and dirty
l'll deal the next one down..
- Sorry.
- What's the sign of when a dealer's hands begin to
shake?
Take over for a while, will ya?
All right men, new deal.
Okay men, here we go, down and dirty
Ace.....seven.....
You know what's eating at you? You showed up the
mob, for kicking it for keeps. So now you're ashamed
to think, well even what you think..
Ain't that right?
You know l don't talk about my customers, so who'd
be the wiser?
Why fight it dealer? Who, for what?
Come over to my place. What do you say?
l'll be around.
They told me you was working here, so l was passing
by and thought l'd come in and have a drink..
- Well, l've been here awhile.
- Doing any good?
All right. Small cut of the game, usual cut of the
drinks.
- Ain't got all night.
- Right. Have something.
- Fine.
- Two doubles.
- You didn't have to do that Frankie.
- No reason you should be losing money by wasting
your time talking to me.
You know you're no waste.
l was hoping you'd come see me.Y
- You know how it is Molly.
- Sure, so busy now.
Here's to it Mollyo.
Mollyo. l haven't heard that since you went away.
- You're looking good Frankie.
- Feel good.
- They tell me you're going to be a drummer now
- Yeah!
- l've got an appointment with a man tomorrow.
- Oh, that's swell.
- Probably l won't get the job though.
- Sure you will.
- l don't play good enough.
- l bet you play fine.
You were always whistling and drumming on tables
and things. Real good too.
l mean it! You've got a natural rythm.
l was thinking, maybe of taking a stage name. Jack
Duvall.
- Jack Duvall,Yeah, that's real class.
- lt is, ain't it?
- That's a swell name. lt fits you Frankie.
- This guy l'm going to see tomorrow, he books all the
big bands.
- lf l get on with him and wear a tux.
- You look swell in a tux.
- l already got the drums.
- Pardon. l need a buck.
Ante up kid.
l got lonely..
l needed somebody and he's a poor beat guy who
needs somebody too.
Everybody needs somebody.
- But you can do better than him.
- Can l Frankie?
Molly l....
l thought a lot about you when l was away About you
and me and Sash.
lt would never work out between you and me as long
as she is sitting upstairs in that chair
lt'd be different if she didn't love me, and she wasn't
so helpless.
You can't make a fool of someone if they love you and
they're so helpless.
That's why l didn't come around sooner. And that's
why l ain't coming around no more.
You understand?
Sure......sure l understand..
- You're a good girl Molly.
- ...real good.
Frankie...
Good luck with that fellow tomorrow
You're not the first to come to me with a letter from Dr
Lennex.
- l've taken care of a lot of you people.
-The doctor told me.
l like doing it, you understand. So don't feel that this
is charity, or anything like that.
- Have you played professionally before?
- Only down at Lexinton.
l see, then you wouldn't mind auditioning? l mean l
know some band leaders who might have an opening,
but they'd have to be sure that you can play
- Oh sure, sure.
- Okay...
There's only one thing Frankie. You see......
A good many people like yourself, they mean well, but
they're weak. They let me down.
l mean l go to all this trouble. Vouch for them, and
they go back on the habit.
- lt makes me look bad.
- Oh, l wouldn't honest!
l'm telling you this because, once a man lets me
down, l'm done with him.
Even if he comes back on his knees. And don't think
that some of them haven't.
- l wouldn't let you down Mr. Lane.
- Good!
l'll call you a week from Friday, about noon.Okay?
- l sure do appreciate it.
- Oh, forget it.
- Good-bye.
Do you like my hair better this way, or swept up
Frankie?
Well you could at least tell me. lt ain't my fault he
don't phone.
What did l say? Just don't hold your breath to hear
from that guy, that's what l said.
He told you noon. Here it is almost 6 o'clock already
so how do you think he'll phone?
l just don't want you should eat your heart out, is all.
Forget the whole thing Frankie, l bet he has.
You think he's got nothing better to do than to worry
about you?
Ha!
Excuse me....
Hello. Oh, just a minute.
lt's for you.
Hello..
-Are you Dr. Dominaski?
- Yes, l came as soon as l could.
Well, how you feel little lady?
- See, the doctor asks how l'm feelilng.
- We'll have you feeling fine in one, two, three.
What is this?
This happens to be an electric blood reverser and
spine manipulator.
- What's the gimmack?
- Gimmack?
lt so happens brother, that l am a member of the
American Association of Medical Psycology,
Hydrology and Divine Healing. Where's the socket?
Cold hands.
Poor cirrculation. Eat lots of hot things. Chilies,
peppers, hot sauces.
- Pickles?
- Not more than 3 a day.
Now lean forward, and we'll vibrate the vertabres.
- Know how l got like l am? My spine was hurt. Oh l
can see that. Your ligaments and vertabres are
locked together.
ln a car accident it was hurt. Three years ago, May
11th.
Maybe you read about it in the papers huh?
This is the car that it happened in. That's me, laying
there. My husband was the one driving the car and
he was drunk.
- Drunk?
- He got me in this accident and smashed me up
good, so that l can't walk anymore or dance anymore.
-And he married me right here, in the hospital chapel.
- Sash!
- Feeling a little better?
- Yeah, much better.
Hey Frankie, guess what? l got that dog for Sash.
Free spirit! Every claw and hair on him is a
champion. Champion of what?
He brings back empties. Here, l'll show you.
He's all dog. You can make money out of him
Frankie.
What he's really good at, is catching those squirrels in
the park, and shaking the peanuts out of them.
Only thing he is trained to chase is a certain kind of
squirrels and they're getting kind of rare in Chicago,
because of the climate changing. You know what l
mean?
So he's just hanging around, waiting for the climate to
change back a little.
He's got a real fighting heart. He's dizzy, but he still in
there trying.
- Take the dog up to Sash.
- Frankie! You're not going with him!
No!
ln a minute dealer.
- Five bucks.
- Last time, it was two.
lt was more than 6 months ago, before you went
away..
They keep raising the price on me.
lf they keep doing that, l'll have to find something to
take its place.
The monkey's never dead dealer. The monkey never
dies.
When you kick him off, he just hides in a corner,
waiting his turn.
The monkey will die waiting. He ain't climbing up on
my back no more.
Never again. l mean it.
Sure.....
Look Frankie! Look how he drinks it. lt's so cute.
He's got a thirst like a bar-fly.
Hello.....
You still expecting that connection to call? For you
own piece of mind, forget him.
The Doc said that l could count on Mr Lane, and the
Doc doesn't lie.
The Doc. Look at me, a doc told you l'd be up and
around in no time, and am l?
Have you seen my sticks? Have you seen my
drumsticks anywhere?
You know what l'm going to get for this little dog? A
little rain coat, like for when it rains.
Plaid maybe, or maybe all yellow
Where are my drumsticks, Sash?
- How'd they get up here?
- You liked that, didn't you?
- Sash, l never keep them up here.
- You drank it all up didn't you?
Sash!
I put them there. I stood right up and I putthem there,
aII right?
- No kidding?
- Maybe Vi, when she was straightening up for me. l
don't know. Stop picking on me.
Frankie...
You can't keep stoning yourself about it..
There must be a million drummers that play better
than you, who can't getjobs.
Just remember that and you're going to feel better
Yeah sure, l will.
Can the noise.
- What's this for Sash?
- What?
Oh Vi. She laid it out for groceries. We owe her even
more.
- You got any?
- No.
l don't know what we're doing with all our money
Don't you get enough cards by Shrika?
- l just do it to kill passtime, that's all.
- Well, what about my passtime?
- What did you say this was for?
- l sit here all the time and you don't even talk to me.
We got any more beer? l'd like some.
Beer bloats Sash, when you can't exercise. Here pick
a card.
Nothing is good for me. l am only 25 and it's like l'm
an old lady already.
- ls it my fault l can't exercise?
- Do you want to pick a card, or don't you want to pick
a card?
No, I don'twantto pick a card. AlI I want isjust, isjust
a Iittle....
-A little what Sash?
- Oh, just a little.....
A little beer, a little fun, a little anything.
l can't dance anymore, l can't swim and l can't even
drink beer.
l don't even know what kinds they got anymore. What
other kinds they got these days Frankie?
All right! Pretend l ain't here. You're wishing all the
time that l'd have gotten killed that night.
l don't wish any such thing.
lf l don't talk, you get mad. lf l say anything, you bite
my head off..
l don't know whether l'm coming or going Sash.
l told you, it gives me headaches.
Well, l've got to practice sometime Sash. lf the job
comes along, l want to be ready.
The job, the job! Take it to your girlfriend if you're
going to practice.
What?
Take them down and give her the headache.
Do you know what you're saying Sash? Do you know
wht you are talking about?
- Don't give me that innocent look.
- l haven't said two words to her since l come back.
- Just cause l sit here, you don't think l know what
goes on?
- Not two words.
l know plenty.
Cut it out will ya Sash.
Take them down to that tramp if you want to make
noise. Take them down to her, why don't you?
All right, l will.
Frankie.....Frankie, l didn't mean.....
- l have 12 cents to a beer. lf l had 15, l'd be all right.
- l've got 6 cents, here ya go.
l ain't going to stand it much longer The heartaches
my old man gives me.
You know what he likes to do most? Tear the dates
off the calendar, watching him. That's suppose to be
my big Saturday night pleasure.
Sometimes he loses all control and tears off the whole
week at once. He'll eat them like a billygoat.
- Know what would fill up that empty spot in your life?
- What?
A dog. Ask a satisfied customer. Frankie that dog l
got you, it makes a big difference in your life, doesn't
it.
Yeah.
l want to see.
- l want to see you.
-After the inning.
Hi Frankie.
- You make out all right with the fellow with the job?
- The drumming job? Yeah, fine, fine.
Well not so fine. He sort of tapped out on me.
He promised to call me, but..
lt's too bad.
There's a million drummers in the world and how do l
rate?
Maybe he lost your number?
lt happens.
Maybe he just wishing you'd keep in touch.
He'd think l was a pest.
Why should he? A good drummer, that's something
that don't turn up everyday
Come on Frankie, call him.
Call him Frankie.
Come on Molly, watch the game huh?
Oh l don't feel like it Johnnie. Why don't you go
ahead, l'll wait for you.
Yes studio B, Monday morning, thank you Mr Lane.
Monday! l got an audition Monday Me! He told me
to join the union and get ready to work.
- Oh that's wonderful.
- You know, he did lose my phone number
He was trying to find me all week long. Here l was
ready to forget the whole thing. Gee, if you hadn't
opened your mouth, l wouldn't have called him.
- Sure you would have.
- l've got an audition with a big band.
- Me on TV.
- Practice a lot Frankie.
Practice? l'll beat those heads to a shred. Only l got
to find a place where.
Sash can't stand the noise.
Molly? Do you think l could put the drums in your
place and sort of drop in once in a while?
Why not?
Molly, why not?
- Johnny wouldn't understand.
- So, what could he do?
lt ain't a question of what he could do Frankie. A
fellow like Johnnie can't do much of anything.
lt's a question of what it does to him. l'm all he has in
the world, and l don't want to hurt him.
- Molly, for crying out loud....
- l want you to know Frankie, a fellow like him.......
- ...Sometimes when we're all alone....
- What does he do? Cry?
He's a lush Molly. He's a 100%/% habitual drunk!
Look, everybody's a habitual something. With him it's
liquor, that's all.
- Please Molly. Mollyo.
- lt ain'tjust that Frankie....
l don't want it to start with us again. Look what you
said about us not seeing each other, it was the truth.
Even if we went away, l'd try to.....
ltjust doesn't add up. lt never did, it never can.
- Well give it a chance. l told you it would one day
-All my life's been ''one day''.
- On and on and on.
- l've got drums, l'm headed for a good job. ls that so
on and on and on?
l make some money, l make Sash well. What's so on
and on about that?
- Don't shut me out Molly l'm trying.
- You wanted to see me?
- No!
- What do you mean ''no''?
- Vi! Here, for what we owe. Frankie, Vi says can't
trust me.
Tell her Frankie, what an honest hustler l am.
Frankie! l guess maybe you could drop in once in a
while.
Thanks Mollyo.
See you tonight Molly.
- How's that?
-Real nice.
- You should have heard what l did a little while ago. ..
- Good huh? l hope the neighbors liked it too.
l'm very big with the neighbors. They keep banging
on the pipes to let me know how much they
appreciate it.
- l won't let it go to my head though.
- You keep playing drums at 5 a.m.....
and you'll see what goes to your head.
Slip me a smile and l'll give you my autograph. You
won't have to fight your way through the bobby soxers
to get to me.
l bet those bobby-soxers go for that.
Tired?
Yes, but in a very nice way. l've been feeling good all
night.
- l joined the muscian's union today.
- Shrika loan you the money?
- Him? Who did?
- Nobody. l'm going to hock the drums.
- Oh Frankie!
- l've got it figured out pretty good.
When l get a job, l'll take an advance and get the
drums out again. ln the meantime, l'll use the
practice pads.
-You should have asked Shrika.
- Haven't even seen him.
- You didn't go to work?
- No, l've been practicing here all night.
- l quit the game Molly. .
- lt woulnd't have hurt you to wait a couple of days
Frank.
l wanted to quit. l'm quitting a couple of things.
ls it bad?
Not too bad.
- You shouldn't have started again.
- Who knows why l started in the first place?
l guess in the beginning you do it only for kicks. l got
my first shot for nothing.
l thought l could take it or leave it alone. So l took it.
And l took it again and again.
One day Louie wasn't around. l nearly went crazy till l
found him.
Lord l was sick!.
l was so sick. You can't be that sick and live.
That's when l knew l was hooked.
There was a 40 pound monkey on my back. The only
way to get along with a load like that, is to keep
getting a fix.
Don't.....
l'm one of the lucky ones, Molly.
l kicked it and l'm not too far hooked to kick it again.
l've had my last fix.
Tell me something. Do you think those bobby-soxers'
will really go for me?
Yes, they will.
Maybe l'll get Sparrow a job with the orchestra.
And when l can get enough money together, l can get
Sash into a real good hospital, so she can walk and
dance again.
And then maybe...
- Who is it?
- Shrika, open up!
Just a minute.
- All right where is he?
- Frankie?
- Frankie! Where is he?
- Well what is it, what did he do?
What'd he do? You know what he did, he quit! No
notice, no nothing.
He sends words by that mistress that he's through. l
had to take the spot myself. Where is he?
- He wasn't at the game?
- Would we be looking for him all over, if he'd been at
the game?
He eats my bread. Six years, he eats my bread. He
gets put away, l send you money regular. He gets out
and l give him his job back.
- Shut up!
-What do you mean ''shut up''?
Do you think it was easy talking men like Williams and
Marquee up to a two-bit game like you?
- Louis.......Louis.....
- l sold them on Frankie.
Why are we getting excited?
They were a bat in the pocket and hungry for action.
We finally get a chance to score big....
..and you lose the deal.
Look Louie l swear. When Marquee and Williams
come, the dealer will be there. Or a playerjust as
good. ...
There ain't none as good.
- Why didn't you offer him more money, a piece of the
play.
- From your end or mine?
What's the difference, whose end? You expect me to
stand here and argue about pennies?
Look.
l'm a musician..
Well, how does it feel?
Well, it feels like....
You'd better hang on to my arm, or l'll go up like a
balloon.
l'm a musician.
- Where are we going?
- l don't know, but l want to buy you something.
- No.
- l've got to spend some money or l'll bust.
- How about one of those, only in green?
- Frankie...
- Maybe a color TV set. They're pretty.
Would you look at this production. ..
And only for cooking. Now who would want a thing
like that?
- Boy, it's goofy huh?
- lt's pretty huh?
- l wonder what he does for a living?
- Him?
He must make a nice dollar. Look at the way he
dresses her and a kitchen like that.
l notice he doesn't help her. l bet he didn't even
marry the girl. Look she ain't even wearing a ring on
her finger.
She takes it off when she cooks, maybe and he's tired
after a hard days' work.
Okay, let him sit there, but at least he could talk to her
once in a while. He doesn't have to sit there with his
nose buried in a magazine.
- l would talk to her.
- What would you say?
l'd say, how you been? How did it go today? What's
for supper?
Steaks for supper and everything went fine today
Steaks! Good. Now how about you and me stepping
out tonight after we eat.
- Why don't we just stay home and listen to music?
- Yeah.
l like that better. We'll just stay home and turn on
some music.
l wish it were Monday already.
- Hi Sash!
- Where have you been?
- Shrika has been here. He said you quit.
-Where have you been? Look!
- Why did you quit him? l've got a try-out on Monday
-lf the band leader likes me, l'm hired.Jeg har mske
fet etjob med et band.
Frankie, go tell Shrika you was fooling, you'll deal.
Maybe this band leader won't like how you play
Sash look. l joined a muscian's union.
Why do you got to go around changing things? Why
can't it be like always? Why do you got to quit dealing
Frankie?
- How we going to live with no money coming in?
- lt'll start coming in Monday.
Suppose they call this great ''try-out'' of. You can't tell
me it's a sure thing, can you?
Frankie, deal for Shrika like always. Forget this
''great'' job!
l quit dealing Sash. l can't take the chance, don't you
understand? lf the joint gets raided and l get picked
up again, Mr. Lane would be through with me.
-And then how will l play with a band?
- How you going to play if Shrika gets your arms
broke?
- What?
-Yeah, right here he said it. And he wanted to slap me
around too.
Why can't it be like always?
Antek!
- You miserable piece of humanity.
- l've got a right to quit if l want.
- Marquee and Williams are coming tomorrow.
- Don't you realize the signifigcance? Leave me
alone.
l'll leave you alone. ln the alley with the cats looking.
That's enough Shrika. lf he don't want to deal, he
don't want to deal.
- What are you talking about?
- Don't you raise your voice to me, you slob.
He's no slave. You can't force him, so what's the
use?
- He....
- We've had the best of him all these years. Don't be
a pig!
He ain't interested.
All right, all right. Marquee and Williams have never
heard of him. Money? Something to blow your nose
on.
l wash my hands.
He's just a pig, that's all.
Still you can't blame him, so much. Let the biggest
ones get away, because the best dealer isn't working
for you anymore.
That ain't easy to swallow.
You're the best all right.
- You're a squeeze player Louis.
-Been tried on you before?
NNah, l'm new around here..
- Are we really asking so much dealer?
- One night. l will...
You help us make a bundle and we'll spread that
sunshine around. Couldn't you use a couple of
hundred?
Maybe 2 5 0?
2 5 0 pays a lot of doctor bills.
- Tomorrow huh?
- Frankie...
Let him make up his own mind.
Okay, but for one night. Win or lose. Sunup, l case
the deck.
Sure, you're the dealer. What a load off. Now l can
sleep. Take care of that arm.
Quite a character huh? Are you jacking up the price
right now, or do you really have that music job?
lf they like what they hear.
Chancy huh? Nervous?
-So, what are we waiting for?
- Don't talk about it. lt's tough enough.
l know, l know. l put down a craving once.
No, candy, sweets. l used to be eating it all the time.
Got examined for the army and they said you've got
sugar in your blood friend. You've got to give up
sweets forever, or it's good-bye Charlie.
- l had to give up candy.
- My gums bleed for you. lt's awful.
lt was. That unfinished feeling that you got all the
time. Well, l don't have to tell you.
- So don't!
-l mean you got this one thing on the mind all the
time.
- Can't stop thinking about it.
-You're just a mine of information aren't you?.
You know what l did?
l said to myself. Okay, off sweets forever. Well,
forever can start tomorrow.
For once in my life, l'm going to eat all the candy that l
can hold. l bought 18 dollars and 20 cents worth of
candy and lugged it up to my room.
All night long, l ate candy
l was sick. l was sweating, but l kept shoving it in.
Ever since then, when l think about candy l say to
myself, well you can't complain. You once had it and
had it good.
You know what l mean?
How's it Mollyo?
- All right Frankie, but where have you been?
- What'll you have?
-A couple of ryes.
All day, l was expecting you'd be in to practice.
Practice? l'll get down there and knock them dead.
lt's all in the wrist and l've got the touch Molly.
Look at that, steady as a rock. lt can do anything l
want it to do.
- Keep the change pal.
- Thanks.
- You got a cigarette Frankie?
- Sure.
You're on it again Frankie. Why, why?
No, listen Molly, listen.
- Why?
-Molly!
- Molly...
- Beat it!
- Take a walk!
- Molly listen to me, l can explain. Molly l just want
to talk.
Will you get out of here!
- Molly.
- Stop it please!.
- You'll lose yourjob. Can't you manage this.
- Molly, listen to me.
Leave me alone, both of you!
Molly!
Molly...Molly!
Molly...listen to me.
Molly. open the door.
Molly would you open the door
Molly!
Molly! Molly, open the door!
Where are you going Molly?
- lf you let me explain, you'll know why l did it.
- Taxi!
MoIIy wiII you Iisten. Let me teII you what's happened.
Where you going Molly?
No Molly! Molly!
- Don't forget to get it cleaned out.
- l already cleaned it.
And say please when you talk to me, or l'll buy my
own and go into business for myself. How's that
Frankie?
Nothing huh?
l'm reminding you Shrika, l get 2-21/2, maybe more.
Would l go back on my word?
How're you feeling dealer?
- Hi ya Shrika.
- Good-evening.
- Yeah?
- ls this the place?
l don't know what place you mean buddy This is the
leather belt and company You want to buy a belt?
Come right in. We've just started. How have you
been?
-l could handle the door better if l was blind.
- Oh, you couldn't heat towels for a barber
- Good-evening Shrika.
- Good to have ya!
You the machine? Man with the golden arm huh?
Let's see you try and take this away..
Here we go, down and dirty.
No ladies allowed, you know that V.
- ls Frankie in there?
- What's the matter?
Sash. l can't get her to sleep. Her and Frankie had
an arguement and she's almost out of her mind. ls he
in there?
- Well, l can't call him now
- l just want to know if he's here?
-l've been bounced around on the street like a pool
ball.
- l've been bounced around on the street like a pool
- l got to get back in.
- Well tell him she's worried, if you get a chance.
- Three aces. Two pairs. Possible straight flush.
-Aces, two hundred.
l'll call your two hundred and raise you two.
l'll have a look for four hundred and l'll spot you three
hundred more.
lt's up to you.
-l don't know, l just don't know.
- You've got three aces, show him.
- He's got a possible straight flush, with a queen
showing.
- l tell you he's bluffing.
He bluffed me out of a couple tonight. You wouldn't
be jerk enough to try it again, would you?
- Bet and find out.
- Well bet, bet. l tell you he's a bluff artist.
- Call it.
- l call it and raise it 500 more.
- Sammy!!
- Jeg ved hvad jeg laver .
l'll have a look and house bumps you 500 more.
- l told you, l told you he had it.
- Shut up and let me think.
- lt's up to you.
- What's the rush, l want to know?
- Your bet, two pairs.
- l heard you. What is this? A forced game? A man
has a right to study his hand.
Bet or fold!
- Lose your hand Sammy.
- l tell you he's got it, don't throw good money after
bad. l know what l'm doing.
What'd you have?
You didn't pay to find out.
Nothing. A lousy two nines. You let him bluff you out
of a full house, with a lousy two nines.
You do that again at this table, and you're through.
Ah, forget it this once dealer. He paid plenty for it.
- You're good dealer, maybe too good.
- What do you mean by that?
- Cut the talk. Deal, deal.
- Come on, get some of this smoke out of here.
- What do you mean too good?
- lf the shoe fits brother.
- Okay, that's it for the deck.
- What?
- Well, we always break up around now
- One more round. What about my money?
-One more round. What about my money?
- Frankie, how about it?
- Nope, just give me what's coming to me.
- One more round huh? l'll deal.
-You? We want to play Machine.
You think l can't sell you a thing or two? Sit down and
we'll get going.
- What about my money?
- As soon as we break.
- Give us a chance. Go home.
- home. You'll get it later. Okay, ante up, here we go.
- 100.
- Yeah....100...
Okay, here we go.
Good morning Frankie.
- ls Louis still here?
- He's doing an apple plexy but they're doing a sweet
in there.
-We're getting murdered.
- You got to get in here and start dealilng. l ain't
taking the slot.
- Look. You got to make it stop.
- No deal, no fix.
- Give me my money and l'll go see someone else.
-Give me my money and l'll go see someone else.
- You owe it to me.
- Take me to court.
- You got to make it stop.
l've got to get some sleep. l've got to be fresh
tomorrow.
Work a few hours, do us a favor. l'll guarentee you'll
feel like a week.
- Please Louis, now.
- Drop dead!
Wait a second.
Okay...
Louis says you've got money for him. So give it to
me, he's waiting.
l know he's waiting. They all say the same thing.
Tell Louis, like he tells us, nothing.
- Not a penny?
- Nope.
- How is it up there?
- The dealer is losing huh?
- What happened to that golden arm? Don't worry
about the dealer. The game's just going on a day and
a half, he'll come through.
Why not, with those educated fingers. Now you see
it, now you don't.
You keep your dirty mouth off the dealer. Frankie
runs a clean game and there ain't nothing in the world
that could make him change that.
Hey Antak....
All right, all right. Can you let me have 1000?
All right, all right. Can you let me have 1000?.
Hold it a minute.
Give me some of that.
l've got to get out of here Louis. l'm dead. l haven't
slept in two days.
lt'll be just a little while now
l ain't doing you any good. The house is still losing.
Stay with it dealer, the class is beginning to tell. Just
stay with it..
- l just can't. My head won't work no more.
- Louis der er ikke flere at ringe til.
- Lippy.
- Can't find him.
- l'll find him. He's loaded.
- l'm getting out of here.
Just a little longer l'm going to make a call, then l'll
take you over to my place.
- Now where were we.
- Jeg vil se.
- Coffee?
- Good and black!
-l can't raise another cent
- De bliver ved at smide penge p bordet
Every pot almost, they're raising and raising until we
are forced out.
- What day is it?
- Kan du ikke finde nogen vi kan lne af?
-What day is it? ls it Monday yet?
-Listen to me...
-Are you listening to me?
- Hvad?
The next big pot they try are forcing you out, you've
got to stay with them.
- Shrika won't let me. He keeps nudging me to fold.
-Shrika won't let me. He keeps nudging me to fold.
You can't be sure though. There's a way you can be
sure. You can do anything you want with those cards.
That's only for fun. l haven't got nerve to do it for real.
- You want to get out of here, don't you?
- What?
- You want to get to that try-out in good condition,
don't you?
- Yeah, l want to get there feeling good.
Well then make sure, you know what l mean.
Let's get on with the game, l feel hot.
Okay dealer...
- l'm in.
Three. King. Jack. .
- l think that's enough.
Call.
- Pair of strays.
l'm back with 500.
House sees.
Three strays, King, Jacks.
l bet 500 bucks.
- Take off your glasses.
- No!
- l didn't know. l didn't know.
- l'll get to you in a second.
l didn't know. lt hasn't happened before. Ask
anybody.
You don't deal for me no more.
- You want him?
- l wouldn't dirty my hands.
How was l to know. You fellows, you know l've been
running an honest game. Tell them!
Frankie...
Everything's all right now Frankie.
Frankie, what's a little cupping around huh? Nothing.
Am l right? You'll see.
You should have seen Shrika's face, when Williams
said he'd get to him in a minute.
He went white! lt was so funny
Cut it out, you hear me!
- You was the best sport l knew my whole life.
- You hear me?
Stay away from me punk!
- Hurry quick!
- l want to get some sleep.
lt's beginning to wear off quit for you? You're a
graduating student. You're going to have to step it up.
- Please hurry.
- All right
- Let's see your money.
- Later, later!
- Right now.
- Trust me this once, will you?
No, l don't do that.
l'll pay you twice as much later, but l got to do
something right now.
l'll even push for you. Louis heard.
-A flipping junkie always says that.
- Louis, please.
Get your dirty hands off me.
Frankie...
- Wake up. Get up!
- Where did you put it?
- Where do you keep it?
- Let him go.
l can't find it.
Frankie, please let me take you home.
l've got to be on time.
Frankie...
What's the matter. Come on, let's try to really cook it.
- Mr. Machine.
- Mr. Lanes.
- Can you read music?
- Yes.
Shelby, let Mr. Machine sit in on this one.
Number 37, it's right in front of you.
Do you know it Mr. Machine?
Okay, let's try.
Mr. Machine, the first four bars are all you. Come on,
let's try it again.
One, two, three, four.
- l'm sorry. .
-Are you all set?
Once again. One, two, three, four
Okay Shelby, let's go.
- Sash, have we any money?
- l need some money. No, what's the matter?
There was some around here yesterday, wasn't
there? l need some money Sash.
Well, there isn't any. What is it Frankie?
What is it?
You can walk? Since when?
What's the angle? What are you and Frankie trying to
prove?
Come on tell me. One hustler to another
Let me in on it or l'll croon for it, you hear? l'll tell
everybody you can walk, you always could.
l'll tell them all you can walk, you old phoney!.
No....Louis!.
No Louis, you can't do that. You can't tell anybody
Please Louis.
- Keep your hands off me.
- Please Louis.
Molly...Molly.
Ain't that the way it happened? They had a fight and
the next thing you know, Louis is falling.
Come on, level Sash. Don't try to out-think me, you'll
only get tangled.
l don't know anything about a fight. l was sleeping
the whole morning, right here in this chair
Then for all you know, it did happen that way While
you were sleeping, Frankie shoved him over.
- He didn't!
- How do you know it? You were sleeping.
lt wasn't like l was sleeping, more like dozing kind of.
l'd have heard a fight, if there was one.
Frankie didn't do it, he wasn't even here.
- When wasn't he here?
- When it happened.
How can you be sure if you was dozing?
I was up when he Ieft. That's how I'm sure. I saw hIm
go.
And he was home this morning.
Only a second. He didn't get in a fight, he was here
only a second.
Why didn't he stick around? Was somebody after
him?
Nobody was after him, nobody. He just wanted some
money is all.
- Money? What for?
- l don't know what for.
A fix! He wanted it for a fix from Louis.
- lt had nothing to do with Louis.
- How do you know?
Cause there was no money. Why would he want to
see Louis for a fix, he there was no money?
To try and get one without money
Okay, l can wait. Wherever he is, sooner or later he's
got to come up for a fix.
Molly, Molly wait please.
lt's finished Frankie. Like l told you.
-But l've got to talk to you Molly,
- No!
Once and for all!
Molly, l've got to talk to you.
You got any money Molly? l need a few dollars.
10 dollars would do it. l'd get it back to you in a few
days.
Or 5 even. Five would be fine, please.
l feel so sick Molly. l hurt all over. l feel so bad.
Don't say no, please don't say no. Why not Molly
why not?
Jump off a rope if you're going to kill yourself, but
don't ask me to help you.
l'll do anything for you Molly...
- But right now you've got to help me. l need a shot.
- No!
Five would do it, or three or two even, but please
hurry.
You mustn't take that dirty stuf no more.
l know, l know you're right. l promise, but right now l
just need a fix. Just one fix.
lt'll help me stop hurting. Then l promise you, l'll kick
it for good. Just a few dollars Molly.
Hello Molly. l just wanted to come and say hello.
- Ain't you going to let me in?
- l asked you please to not bother me any more.
- l miss you.
- Look, l'm awfully tired Johnny.
- l'll stay only a few minutes.
- No.
- Who's in there with you?
- Go away Johnny and don't come back.
Who is it? Not the dealer! You ain't hiding him, are
you?
- You wouldn't be dumb enough to be an accessory
would you?
- What do you mean accessory?
He killed Louis. The cops are looking for him this
minute.
- Frankie Machine.
- ls he in there?
- No.
- l'm coming in!
Not if you ever want to see me again.
- Will you meet me tomorrow.
- Yeah, l'll be around the bar
Maybe not tomorrow, but soon.
l miss you.
Honest, l didn't.
What am l going to do?
- Go tell Bedner, it wasn't you.
- l couldn't.
l couldn't stand up to the cops the way l am.
Look at me. l'd say anything they'd want me to say
just for a shot.
- Then get cured first.
-What are you talking about? How am l suppose to
get cured.
-You did it once..
-That was with help, with medicine and doctors.
l can't go apply at Lexington with a murder hanging
over my head.
Couldn't you do it without going there?
You mean just stop?
Cold turkey?
You don't understand. The pain.
What else can you do?
All l need is just one shot, just one.
Okay.
All right, here take it!
Here, go on take it all. Cause after that one shot, all
you're going to need is another.
And then another and another Take it!
Take it!
- Why should you hurt, like other people hurt?
- You had a dog's life, but never a break.
Why try to face it, like most people do? No just roll up
all your pains, into one big hurt and then flatten it with
a fix.
What do you think you'll find just outside that door?
Don't you think Bedner knows what you are, and what
you need?
Just to get through that next hour...
Don't you know, he's just waiting for you to come and
get it.
Go on. Let him kill you!
Let him kill you. lt'll be quicker and better than doing
it your way.
No!
l won't let him kill me. No!
And l won't run into no grave.
But kicking it......
A guy can't do it by himself.
l'll help.
You know what you are letting yourself in for? lt ain't
pretty.
And it could be dangerous.
lf they find you here, then they find you, is all.
l don't mean dangerous from Bedner. l mean
dangerous for me.
Sometimes a junkie will kill, to get away from the
treatment.
Understand?
So if you've got any knives or scissors in the house,
you've got to put them away for a while.
And don't let me out of the room. No matter what l
say, or promise, or how much l beg.
Cause if l get out, it'll only be for a fix.
That's the way it is. Do you understand?
Just lock me in the room. And if l try to make a break
for it, just stop me any way you know how
And no matter how much you see it hurting me, don't
try to help me with pills or dope or anything else.
Do you think you can handle it?
Here we go.
Down and dirty.
You can't hold me.
Sit down.
You can't hold me. l ain't got all my marbles, you
know that Captain.
Write down the cases Sparrow.
- l didn't do nothing.
- But Frankie did something all right.
Now, l want you to tell me about it.
Whoever killed that peddlar, should get a ticker-tape
parade. Yeah, and maybe l'd lead the band, but l still
want you to tell me about it.
Listen to me Sparrow. When we catch him, he stands
trial, whether you talk, or whether you don't.
The only question is, do l ticket you as an accessory?
Bedner, don't nail me to the cross. He's the only guy
l've ever had for a friend.
He's nobody's friend anymore. He smash you with a
steam roller, if you got between him and a pop in the
arm.
Come on talk Sparrow.
Okay, beat it.
Let me out!
Yes?
- l thought l'd come and see how you've been Sash.
-All alone, that's how l've been.
Something to eat. Sausage.
All alone and worried sick. Where is he? Do you
know where he is?
Did he go to you?
What do you want anyway?
l didn't tell Bedner anything. The papers, they twist
everything all up.
They wouldn't be able to, if you didn't let them.
l can't help what they do. What do you expect me to
do, sitting here?
Just tell Bedner that Frankie wasn't here when it
happened. That he didn't do it.
- l never said he did.
- But that's how it sounds, if he was the only one
around at the time.
And you know it was somebody else.
What do you mean? Who?
don't know. But maybe Bedner could figure it out if he
didn't think it was Frankie.
What business is it of yours anyway?
l just want to help, that's all.
Who are you kidding? You think l don't know what
you really want?
You think l don't know what you and him have been
up to behind my back, while l had to sit here all these
years?
- Had to sit here all these years.
- No Sasha, you've got it wrong.
No! You've got it wrong! He put me in this chair, and
as long as l sit here, he'll never leave me.
- He knows he belongs to me.
- Sash, l came only to help.
l wouldn't want to live it he left me, and l would rather
see him dead, than go to you.
- Sash, please.
- YES, get out of here!
GET OUT OF HERE YOU LOUSYTRAMP!
Get out!
Frankie NO!
- l can't stand it any longer
-Just a little longer.
Please help me. Keep me warm.
l've got to get out and get a fix.
Open the door, or l'll kill you..
- l'll kill you.
- Frankie, listen, if you......
- But l do have something put away to make it stop.
- Give it to me quick!
Where? l'll get it.
Molly! Molly!
Let me out!
Molly open the door.
Frankie? Frankie, answer me.
Frankie answer me. Are you all right?
Don't think you can fool me into opening this door l
won't.
Are you all right Frankie? Please answer me.
Molly, if you love me, kill me, please!
Oh, l'm so cold.
Make me warm.
Molly...
Please Molly, make me warm...
Oh Molly, l'm so cold!
Oh God, O God.
Please make me warm Molly.
l'm so cold..
- l waited for you in the bar.
- l told you it might not be right away
l thought maybe you were sick or something. l just
wanted to tell you, don't look for me at the bar
anymore. He threw me out last night, we had a little
argument.
- So make it the Safari huh?
- Yeah, sure Johnny, sure.
Pretty good, huh Molly?
- Take it slow now.
- Oh, l'm all right.
Just a little rocky.
lt's the most gorgeous day l ever saw.
l think it's the first day l ever saw.
l've got a craving for something sweet. Have you got
anything sweet?
- Sugar?
- Gimme!
More, come on, more.
How can you Frankie?
I neverfeltthis good In my Iife. I feeI IIke aII the thIngs
Insise of me are settlIIng Into pIace.
Thanks Molly. Mollyo!
- Look out, you'll scrape your face off!
- l don't care.
- You got a razor l can use?
- Can l trust you with one?
Cross my heart.
- ls this the place?
- Yeah.
- Okay, come on.
- No please, you don't need me up there.
-Where is he Molly?
- He didn't do it, honest.
l'm not a judge. They pay me to bring him in, that's
all.
lf you tell me where he is, l promise you that he'll get
every break a jockey can get.
- He's no jockey either. That's finished.
- Oh sure, you bet.
- You can see for yourself.
- He ain't running away from you. So, where is he?
- With Sash.
-All right Molly. Let's go see.
- Hello Sash.
- What are you doing here?
- Frankie, don't you know that Bedner is looking for
you?
- Don't worry about it Sash, l ain't afraid.
- l didn't do it and you know that
- Who did then?
l've come to tell you something Sash.....
- l'm leaving here.
- Bedner will arrest you. He told the newspapers
you.....
- What?
- l'm leaving.
You won't have to worry about money or anything. l
find a way to send some regular to you .
-And Vi will take good care of you.
-Leaving me!?
Not leaving you Sash, just leaving.
You saw what happened since l came back. Like Dr.
Lennex told me.....
l got in the same old routine and before l knew it, l
was on it again.
But you can't leave me. You've got to stay and take
care of me.
l know l'm responsible for how you are Sash....
but l can't go around the rest of my life stoning myself
about it.
l've been carrying my heart ever since it happened.
Even now it hurts me to think about it, but.....
Well, it's not that l want to leave, l've got to leave.
You mustn't leave Frankie! You mustn't.
Sash....
- Say good-bye to me Sash.
- You think you're fooling me?
l know what's pulling you away Molly!
- No.
- Yeah, you just go so that you can be with that little
tramp!
- Frankie no...
- Good-bye Sash.
No Frankie, please don't leave.
Frankie no, don't leave me.
Get dressed Sash..
Sash!
Sash Stop!
Sash, don't move.
Don't try to talk. You're going to be all right.
l love you so much!